and to be reminded that actually this is
getting to the point where Florida is
about to be a terrorist state to many of
us here in America certainly as a
lesbian as a black woman I don't want to
have anything to do with the place
um and I think about all the other
people who don't want to travel there
either and so I think it was very clever
on behalf of the NAACP I thank them for
issuing this broad uh guidance and you
know really what it does is it turns a
remarkable uh I think lens on the United
States and highlights how bigotry and
bias and ignorance do as much harm as we
accuse other countries of doing to
people that they suppress